I got Daniel over here let's hit him up
Daniel what's up buddy hey Rich how's it
going good what do you got for me today
well a quick question before I get to
the main one uh the the reason why uh
so why women are generally attracted to
you know
quote-unquote Bad Boys is it for the
same reason why uh so many guys are
attracted to women like uh Sharon
Stone's character from you know the
movie Basic Instinct
no it's not uh that's
that's what Society wants you to believe
let's let's apply what works for women
to men well if women are hypergamous
then men are hypogamus that's some made
up [ __ ] that some [ __ ] nerds made
up men and women are totally different
in just about every regard right so
guy like guys prioritize availability is
what we prioritize
you know we don't we don't generally you
know prioritize oh let's go for the
Sharon Stone uh like the siren you know
sort of thing right like sure Sirens are
an archetype that guys go for right
there's no question about I mean there's
a lot of sirens right now on The Mantel
swamp that are getting a lot of guys
attention right some of them are just
average at best seem to be honest with
you but
um
no it's not the same thing it's that's
not it at all does that make sense I
mean yeah it does make somewhat sense I
mean if you start with like any of these
ideas between men and women with they're
exactly the same
we can eat the same meal we'll drink the
same water but our sexual strategies are
different we're even physically built
differently right like men have much
more upper body strength than women
all right and uh another thing I wanted
to get to is that uh about five days ago
I met my cousin who came from uh United
States he lives there and he uh he works
there and uh he he brought his American
girlfriend with him and uh uh within
where are you in South Africa
sorry me were you in South Africa uh no
Czech Republic Chuck okay
well but but I've studied uh two and a
half years in Australia okay
uh but but anyways uh at first we kind
of got along because uh we're both
interested in coding but uh it's the the
moment I as I said that if I ever
traveled to United States I would love
to go to Florida or uh Texas she
immediately started complaining about
them as being red States and the
you know she she immediately went on the
usual uh woke stuff
on the
I I didn't want to cause an argument
when the the there were like five of us
around the table
um so I I've kind of did didn't
challenge her opinions uh that much
and uh
since that conversation I really became
worried about my cousin that uh
unplugged like is he red pilled or or
what's his story I don't think he's red
filled uh is that a feminist for sure
uh he's he's not a feminine guy that's
that's for sure you know he likes to
play Ice Hockey for example yeah you
know he uh
he knows how to get girls okay so what's
your concern like you're worried about
this relationship with you know that
he's got with this gal yeah that's uh
that eventually he may want to marry her
and have kids with her and uh we both
know what happens to guys like when uh
it you know in the Western World when uh
how old you know
he's about 28 28 29.
you know what if you want to start with
something simple because that's really
the only way to start if you want to
start
um show them the the 20 red flags right
you can show it to them in my book you
can download the chapter for free off my
website I had the link up earlier
um and be like hey you know I came
across this there's 20 red flags here I
noticed my ex-girlfriend had you know a
certain number of them like what do you
think like you know just making a
conversation piece
you know you basically run it up the
flagpole and see what he does with it
and he's like well hang on a second you
know Violet has you know four or five of
these what's this guy talking about why
is this a red flag and then you can kind
of you know get in the conversation
there the thing being though is that
most guys don't want to change right
like most guys it's like a girl you know
gives him attention she likes him she
touches his pee pee they get into a
relationship you know and then they sort
of take it from there and if he doesn't
have a lot of experience and if he's
still plugged in The Matrix he's still a
tool and all that sort of stuff then
he's he's gonna have a hard time with a
lot of it right like if you tell him
like Hey dude you're dating a feminist
um what are you doing you know guys that
generally do that get wrecked sort of
thing you can have conversations around
that and see where it goes but his
current strategy is to avoid all these
topics all together all right we'll have
fun with that then just just read him
his last rights and and find some new
friends to hang out with you know you
can kiss your cousin goodbye until he
ends up going through what he's going to
go through because he doesn't want to
hear it
no no that's not what I said we met each
other uh about like I don't know I think
was we haven't seen each other for five
years and this is the first time we've
met okay well maybe I misunderstood but
did you just say that he doesn't want to
hear about it no no he when his
girlfriend wants to talk about these
subjects he tries to avoid them because
he he himself doesn't really subscribe
to this walk stuff
well
is he planning on marrying this girl
uh I don't know yet they have haven't
said anything yet but uh if look man if
he knocks her up then that could be you
know the Prelude to all of it as well
too but
if he doesn't subscribe to it and you
generally have the same
view on life and you know men leading
women following masculine energy
feminine energy all that sort of stuff
yeah look somebody just dropped in a
shot I'll put up on the screen he's just
gonna delay the inevitable like you like
you gotta deal with it right I mean if
the whole concept of frame in a
relationship
this the earlier that you start
maintaining frame the better off that
you're going to be these guys that are
like
five years into their marriage and
um they dated for three years before
eight years together
they're Googling stuff for youtubing
stuff why won't my wife bang me maybe
they find my video or a friend Fords and
something like that and then they learn
about frame and like how do I get the
frame oh this Frame thing seems like you
know it's a very good thing like how do
I get this frame back sort of thing I
probably had it when I was younger you
know you know when we met sort of stuff
and it's it's very very difficult once
you've gone through betaization through
a thousand concessions for years to all
of a sudden say nope not having it she's
gonna be like get the [ __ ] out of here I
run this show you're my [ __ ] like if
you're in that kind of relationship it's
very difficult to change that so if he
wants to have a good relationship with a
woman and that's the way that he is he
needs to start applying frame early in
the relationship and if a woman can't
enter his frame because they want to go
on about wokeness or rainbows or
whatever the [ __ ] it is that they want
to go on about
see ya replace him
next
that's how guys need to operate it's not
that complicated and if guys don't
operate in that sense they're going to
run into problems you froze up I don't
know if you can still hear me I I heard
you ever the whole conversation okay
makes sense yes yes it does and the one
last thing before before I go
um
uh about uh three years ago I became
interested in martial arts a bit and uh
last year I started and started studying
a lot coding and uh I want to become a
uh web3 developer
and uh
so and my question is how do I balance
these two things out because initially I
I gave a lot of time uh you know into
uh training you know it was it was
boxing and mma's the combination of both
but uh
thank you
dude you should have all the time in the
world do whatever the hell you want
you only sleep like eight hours a day so
why can't you find the time to do what
it is that you want to do
well I'm because
I I have a feeling that that's uh ever
since I started coding I I kind of I
started neglecting the martial arts
training and uh complicate life justify
why okay it's it's not a conversation
piece dude this is not like high level
stuff this is basic stuff fine like find
the time you will you will find ways to
make things happen or you will find
excuses there's there's one or two
things that always happens it's just you
know that's just it look last thing
about your cousin is he from the Czech
Republic or is he yes yes he is why the
hell is he dating American chicks dude
Czech women are beautiful
yeah dumper like just tell them to find
a checker like they're beautiful and
they're feminine like it doesn't make
any sense
you're starting off 2023 not very well
with some of these things
she if it wasn't for for those ideology
she's indoctrinated that she she would
be a very I I I just stick around her
and uh I think she's happy with her I
don't think she's a mean girl
she sounds like a real pain in the ass
while you're describing her views on the
world
well yes uh but but I don't think it's
necessarily her fault I think she's just
been it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
that's if that's the belief system that
somebody operates with then it doesn't
matter how pretty they are it doesn't
matter how good of a person they are
that is how they operate they are they
are always going to default to toxic
feminism and in order to be a feminist
today you have to have an oppressor
which means you're going to play the
victim card this is not a this is a red
flag this is red flag number two on my
list
yeah get the list read it read it again
look you want a easy and fun life when
it comes to women stay away from
inviting women into your life or if your
cousin is red pilled or or he thinks
this way anyway but he doesn't recognize
it identify red flags and avoid them
you're not going to change these checks
is is there a way he could uh you know
change her mind or make her think
differently about the world with
boundaries and frame
stop talking I don't want to hear about
red state blue State stuff I like
Florida and I like Texas I like guns and
I believe in the Second Amendment so
stop talking about this nonsense
glad to hear you
that's a pretty good indication that
you're with the wrong person because
your values don't align okay
then it's it's just like get lost then
because that's how I feel like why are
guys not opening up their mouths and
telling these gals what they think why
are they shutting their mouths for these
bimbos with ridiculous opinions that are
covered in red more red flags than a
Chinese Communist parade why aren't guys
able to stand up
because we've been pussified we've been
told to shut up we've been told to just
agree we've been told to just go with
the flow
right change that change that change it
for yourself and set the standards for
yourself right show him that you're
leading by example encourage him to do
the same if you want the best for your
family for your blood then encourage him
to do the same otherwise you're going to
be sitting there listening to this
[ __ ] at family dinners and
Thanksgiving and Easter and all these
other events you know where you get
together and you're not going to like
the check and she's probably going to
ruin his life and you may not even see
the guy again because generally speaking
these gals separate guys from their
family because they don't want them to
associate with values that don't align
with their crazy nonsense
um
is what it is
you know I'm speaking the truth man I'm
not lying to you
understood all right my friend take care
see ya I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out
[ __ ]